[Music]
a spirit airlines flight from mccarran
had a stop on its track seconds before
liftoff this happened last night and
passengers were left waiting well into
the early morning hours to get answers
victoria saha joins us from the newsroom
with the ordeal from one passenger
victoria
having something go wrong with your
plane could be the worst nightmare for
many of us when we get on a flight one
passenger on flight 334 on route to
pittsburgh last night says she thought
the plane was already in the air when
she felt it
hit the ground
these are pictures passenger jennifer
allen of las vegas shared with us the
aftermath of her spirit flight slamming
its breaks seconds before takeoff
emergency personnel getting into the
plane to escort passengers out
spear airlines tells us the pilots
decided to not take off due to a
potential maintenance issue the plane
braked safely upon taxing to the gate
the aircraft experienced a flat tire and
that plane was not just taxing i mean we
were
full speed i mean seconds from lifting
off i actually thought we had
even begun to lift off allen says
passengers were left waiting for hours
for a new plane to come but it did not
she rescheduled her flight for later
this evening
the ffaa says the maintenance issue had
to do with the airspeed indicator and
that the pilots thought it would be best
to not fly in that moment the 9 40 p.m
flight from last night took off this
morning close to 10 a.m reporting live
from the newsroom victoria saha 8 news
now